[Musique]
ça se trouve avec mon premier appel au
sein du service
lorsque j'ai vu une lettre du brasier
c'est une raison de guerre
[Musique]
tranquillement pas vite on a des choses
qui se mettent en place
[Musique]
disons après l'incendie le très traverse
toujours Lac-Mégantic mais l'endroit
n'est plus le même
[Musique]
un nouveau centre-ville a été érigé sur
les centres de l'ancien la caserne des
pompiers est elle-même toute neuve et
comme les autres nouveaux bâtiments elle
se remarquent en raison des panneaux
solaires qui ornent sans toi et beaucoup
de panneaux la technologie on voit que
ça évolué c'est sûr que tu es de voir la
nouvelle caserne l'installation des
panneaux solaires
oui ça fait un changement aussi de
discussion par rapport aux événements
qui se sont passés de le disant on
avance vers l'avenir on veut tourner la
page on veut prendre en main notre futur
je pense que c'est un gros pas qui était
réalisé la nouvelle caserne et le
dernier maillon du micro-réseau de
Lac-Mégantic une installation électrique
autonome unique au Québec tout ce qui
est de ce côté-là est inexistant en fait
issu de la volonté de ses habitants de
se projeter en avant c'est 7 millions de
litres de pétrole bruts qui se sont
déversées dans notre centre-ville dans
notre lac alors pour nous ça fait du
sens d'arriver avec un projet qui est à
base d'énergie renouvelable qui réduit
la dépendance au pétrole on voit que bon
présentement on a zéro kilowatts qui
provient du réseau principal
d'Hydro-Québec donc on est autosuffisant
avec les panneaux solaires ici même les
bornes de recharge pour voiture
électrique sont alimentés par le soleil
en tout une trentaine d'immeubles ont
été accordés des bâtiments
administratifs la gare la garderie un
immeuble d'habitation et le centre
sportif qui constitue le cœur de ce
réseau électrique autonome il peut
produire à lui seul plus de 500 kW
d'électricité on a environ 1700 panneaux
sur le toit où on est actuellement on a
utilisé l'ensemble de la surface
disponible au toit du centre sportif
pour intégrer de la production solaire
précurseur le micro-réseau de Lac
Mégantic se voulait d'abord un
laboratoire grandeur nature pour
Hydro-Québec c'était la première fois
qu'on allait travailler avec des
panneaux solaires avec du système de
stockage d'énergie donc il y avait
beaucoup d'apprendre de comment ces
nouvelles technologies-là pouvait
impacter notre réseau puis comment ils
pouvaient impacter les clients
grâce aux panneau solaire et à ses
énormes batteries le centre ville de
Lac-Mégantic peut se débrancher du
réseau principal d'Hydro-Québec et tenir
le coup pendant plusieurs heures en cas
de panne généralisée avec ces deux
batteries là qu'on est ici on peut
monter jusqu'à des îlots qui peuvent
aller le 8 10 12 heures le consécutive
où on est complètement déconnecté du
réseau principal source de résilience
donc et de fierté ici mais pas seulement
des économies d'énergie importantes
parce que on produit localement notre
énergie on en est très fier et on doit
montrer l'exemple pour réduire la
dépendance au pétrole son est une petite
communauté à lac-mégantique mais
ultimement on a tous notre part à faire
et nous on a choisi de la faire et on
espère que d'autres vont emboîter le pas
également
un exemple qui pourrait bien ne pas
rester unique très longtemps
hydro-Québec a bien étant sur
d'appliquer ailleurs les leçons apprises
ici dans les communautés isolées du
Grand Nord entre autres ou aux Îles de
la Madeleine actuellement alimenté par
des centrales thermiques ou diesel se
tourner vers le soleil donc pour tourner
le dos au pétrole